good morning believe nation today's
message is follow your passion over to
you pep guardiola talking of talented
plans for any young viewers out there
who want to become a professional
footballer what one bit of advice would
you have for them they have to look
inside of themselves if they have
passion that's all if they have passion
they can do it if they play just because
it's always going to be always it'll be
famous you can go out with a beautiful
girl so we know a lot of money that is
no chance do it do it and do it not just
about the food what they think about
life if you like to do something and you
can spend thousand million hours in that
because you love it all the
professionals stay a long long time
playing every three days in important
games because they love the game but
they don't love the game they don't love
training they can stay forever so listen
this is probably one of the most common
rules that we get consistently across
successful people in all walks of life
athletes entrepreneurs musicians
inventors passion presentation passion
passion passion passion passion passion
passion passion passion passion passion
passion passion Russian people who reach
the top in whatever they're doing
consistently say that you need to follow
your passion and I think the number one
reason why people fail in business in
life is because they're not doing the
thing that they're passionate about is
because they're making too many
decisions with the head and not the
heart work for every major decision that
you make in your life the big ones you
have to make with your heart and not
your head because your head will lead
you down the wrong path your head only
understands the logical world that
currently exists where your heart can
help you create something that does not
yet exist and you have the ability the
skills the talent the tenacity to be
able to create something that nobody
else has ever done before
you need to unless you want to sit
inside a box that somebody else has
created for the rest of your life
because they're off creating something
new and you're just taking orders and
following rules unless that's the life
that you want then you're going to have
to create something that is unique that
is different that is you that reflects
who you are as an individual that nobody
else can do you know I'm doing my thing
nobody else can do it like me I'm
enjoying what I'm doing right you need
to find that for yourself as well and
stop listening to your head and that's
where it gets scary because you get this
idea you get all passion excited about
it and then your head kicks in and says
wow that's never been done before that's
risky
that's scary because it's never been
done before why are we gonna be the ones
to do it and then that's where you stop
yourself and that's where maybe your
friends stop you and your parents stop
you and the people around you stop you
and then the brakes come off on your
dreams and you stop we're what you need
to do is have these things working
together where the idea the vision the
passion excitement comes from your heart
and then you use your head to figure out
how to go about doing it instead of
saying I can't do it because it's never
been done before use your head to ask
yourself how can I do it this big crazy
thing that I want to do how can I do it
and when you start asking your head
those questions it's gonna start giving
you back answers that support your dream
and so I think most people fail in
business or if you like at 80 90 percent
whatever the stat is of businesses that
fail I think it's because people just
didn't do a big reason the biggest
reason is people didn't do something
that they were actually super passionate
about they looked at a money-making
opportunity they opened up a magazine of
the 100 top opportunity is to go and
chase we used to make money in 2017 you
know and they just chase those things I
think people make that same mistake in
their careers they go into the jobs that
their parents want them to do whether
they go into the safe route and then
they never climb up to where they could
go you never reach your potential
because you're not doing the thing that
you're supposed to be doing because you
listen to this and this will always hold
you back follow your passion
so my question of the day today is
what was the biggest struggle that
you've had to make what decision was the
hardest one between the heart and the
head and how did you make it
I'm curious leaving the comments below
I'm gonna join in the discussion thank
you guys so much for watching have an
amazing day I believe in you and hope
you continue to believe in yourself and
whatever your one word is and I'll see
you again tomorrow morning for another
shot of interesa